dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this work
is about performing useful image
restoration tasks with a convolutional
neural network with an additional twist
its main use cases are as follows one in
the case of JPEG artifact removal the
input is this image with many blocky
artifacts that materialize during
compression and the output is a restored
version of this image to image in
painting where some regions of the input
image are missing and are to be filled
with useful and hopefully plausible
information three super resolution where
the input image is intact but is very
coarse and has low resolution and the
output should be a more detailed higher
resolution version of the same image
this is the classic enhance scenario
from the CSI TV series it is typically
hard to do because there is a
stupendously large number of possible
high resolution image solutions that we
could come up with as an output for
image denoising is also a possibility
the standard way of doing these is that
we train such a network on a large
database of images so that they can
learn the concept of many object classes
such as humans animals and more and also
the typical features and motives that
are used to construct such images these
networks have some sort of understanding
of these images and hence can perform
these operations better than most
handcrafted algorithms so let's have a
look at some comparisons do you see
these bold lettered labels that classify
these algorithms as trained or untrained
the bicubic interpolation is a classic
untrained algorithm that almost naively
tries to guess the pixel colors by
averaging its neighbors this is clearly
untrained because it does not take a
database of images to learn on
understandably the fact that these
results are lackluster is to show that
non learning based algorithms are not
great at this the SR rest net is a state
of the art learning based technique for
super resolution that was trained on a
large database of input images it is
clearly doing way better than by cubic
interpolation and look we have
deep-fryer algorithm that performs
compare ibly well but is labeled to be
untrained so what is going on here and
here comes the twist this convolutional
neural network is actually untrained
this means that the neuron weights are
randomly initialized which generally
leads to completely useless results on
most problems so no aspect of this
network works through the data it has
learned on all the required information
is contained within the structure of the
network itself we all know that the
structure of these neural networks
matter a great deal but in this case it
is shown that it is at least as
important as the training data itself a
very interesting and esoteric idea
indeed please make sure to have a look
at the paper for details as there are
many details to be understood to get a
more complete view of this conclusion in
the comparisons beyond the images
researchers often publish this psnr
number that you see for each image this
is the peak signal-to-noise ratio which
means how close the output image is to
the ground truth and this number is of
course always subject to maximization
remarkably this untrained Network
performs well on both images with
natural patterns and man-made objects a
reconstruction from a pair of flesh and
no flash photography images is also a
possibility and the algorithm does not
contain the light leaks produced by a
highly competitive handcrafted algorithm
a joint bilateral filter quite
remarkable indeed the supplementary
materials and the project website
contain a ton of comparisons against
competing techniques so make sure to
have a look at that if you would like to
know more the source code of this
project is available under the
permissive Apache 2.0 license if you
have enjoyed this episode and you feel
that eight of these videos a month is
worth a dollar please consider
supporting us on patreon $1.00 is almost
nothing but it keeps the papers coming
recently we have also added the
possibility of one-time payments through
PayPal and cryptocurrencies I was
stunned to see how generous our crypto
loving fellow scholars are since most of
these crypto donations are anonymous and
it is not possible to say thank you to
everyone individually I would like to
say a huge thanks to everyone who
supports the series and this applies to
everyone regardless of contribution just
watching the series and spreading the
word is already a great deal of help for
us thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
you